hi I'm Greg Serena Aria every day she
has one of two voices that she likes to
do so guess what guys Renee is on
Instagram Twitter in YouTube follow her
Alabama Leah so we're gonna watch a
video a silence of love a Thai life
insurance commercial the life insurance
oh no it's a life insurance commercial
yeah means they're really light-hearted
and funny oh they're funny this is uh so
many people who sent this in first when
I caught a leavin that's a cool name of
leaving I like that I'm 11 Aaliyah or
nay you should do comedy all right here
we go Renee let's uh let's do this I
don't think this is going to be a crier
I cried really easily no you don't you
can possess that level of emotion that
quantity we need
palm T maybe mine huh parking my food
[Music]
ha party day you may see genius ball
party to die now Pakistani guy
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
monkey at the mini party it is by my paw
Pyrrha good Marcus
Lulla indeed elected hyperactivity makes
me want to get life insurance yeah
totally that was one of the darkest
commercials she looks like Cooper barely
like whoa kind of shocked by how dark
this is yeah
look at what I did not see that coming I
did not see her hurting herself also
like maybe appreciate your dad more yeah
your dad was nothing but cool the whole
time and all you did was like oh I wish
I am this better than your dad's pretty
cool how would you just wish your dad
wouldn't you rather than being my day
wish I had a different like I want to
know I shouldn't just didn't appreciate
her dad it's fine because she already
killed at school all the time bullies
y'all quality people
so you just mad like everyone right now
they wrote another chop yeah I decided
to see one of these commercials where
it's like really emotional I tend to
like tear up sometimes cry a lot what's
starting so dark I was like I'm kind of
surprised by just how dark this is I
wasn't getting like emotional I was like
well it was just shockingly dark right
now
yeah that happened for me as well
talking like oh I'm probably an
accredited Yahoo probably died but I
kept thinking he's going to die this
nice guy and then it took a turn I mean
like what they want with this suicide
and she's like he's you're bleeding
ribbing from her a ham and cheese on the
gurney you're just kind of shot on
commercial right now I read almost
laughing when I saw the drawing of the
fathers are and how their heads to her
literally type like 1970s disco dancers
an edger are yeah I couldn't take that
part that one thing seriously but the
rest I was like okay calm down
commercial so like I had the perfect
idea to make it okay yeah in case your
daughter tries to commit suicide you
should get some life insurance I was
just so dark I can't get around dark by
well you know it's not only what I like
about these commercials is that there's
there's different shades of gray in life
and it's like a lot of times it's like
Oh something happy happening and
something sad or something yes added
something happy this is just like
everything [ __ ] from beginning and isn't
getting better for me yeah I usually in
the commercial like it start about like
oh this is Grayson relationship and then
it just no it started from the bottom of
yours if you liked when I really get
affected is when there's like when
there's colors of life and they're not
wear it it's just like over the saddest
thing we can think of right now
but come at me I think that's how you
break people's hearts in these
commercials is when you okay if you can
make someone like relate to someone or
sympathize with someone in like a one or
two minute commercial yeah and then
break our hearts and Rosalind we were
like who it why why would they
appreciate your father from the
beginning yeah yeah and then it just
positives though I think I think I think
the guy boots jack is really good good
action he had a lot of life in his
performances I felt he's this guy who's
like he has a disability but he's doing
the best he can
okay because you're right he does kind
of make you like kind of dislike the
girl a little bit because I get like why
she's like upset and a little resentful
but I got to a certain point where I'm
like why are you studying yourself so
you're not the mute one you know yeah I
include you death and you I think he was
just meeting you because the daughter
fell over he heard it no he could have
felt the vibration though because she I
think she used the gun and I was like
live it falling over was a gunshot she
like cut her wrists and fell over right
because I don't know I thought it was a
gunshot because she said I wish you
could hear my voice or something that
made me think you oh yeah yeah girl
again I just don't know from the
beginning she was just like I wish I had
another fatherless it just got to me you
know I mean she's the one feeling bad
for herself the whole time instead of
being like oh my gosh my dad brought me
home a cake or oh my gosh my dad really
cares about me it's always like the
negative focus on the positive yeah I
can't even ever even know her name
I remember see tough though and you're
like going to school you're bullied for
such a thing yeah I won't be annoyed for
anything but like especially that kids
jeez
me ya Dums dad something about something
yeah they can think dumb daughter dumb
daughter and then on the board at
remember what it said it was very good
insults to yawn yeah dramatically smack
72 recent YouTube comments so they
cannot I do some veterans up because he
liked the even this boyfriend just kind
of looks like a douchebag I don't know
well I get a douchey vibe from the
boyfriend I do please wearing like a
wife beater
yeah they an American oh it looks very
out of place
yeah like missus like you should not
lose like in a private school and he's
like nah yeah just like the rebellious
he dropped out yeah on school he's like
talk about with me I read you like oh my
life yeah and he kind of played a weird
role in this commercial to this is the
first commercial where I wasn't a huge
fan of it I didn't like this I'm gonna
be real with you I didn't like this wow
that's because we have no emotions no
that's our problem and we don't believe
in therapy only laugh therapy only laugh
therapy like this is pretty funny
you dig about this little thing it's a
sterile fall fiction it's not really you
can laugh at it alright well hey I'm so
glad we got to watch it that wow there's
some comments every time I watch this
commercial I cry hmm did I think about
this commercial I cry now more concern
for this person who commented okay yeah
can you imagine just sitting there and
I'm thinking about this commercial and I
cry you should have her on first yeah
she's really good though I mean it's a
sermon even though I'm not a big fan of
the character portrayal of it I thought
she was really good oh yeah I just
didn't like who she plays yeah when
she's like crying and stuff though like
this looks like people really she's like
I don't want thinking of actors when I'm
watching this stuff these look like
people were being captured at the time
yeah yeah no they're very talented
everyone got given that credit okay
girlfriend ah this commercial is better
than most movies what movies are you
watching yeah Ashley Johnson is
wondering what crap movies are you
watching me tiger sometimes yeah stop
watching your white chicks
and watch a real [ __ ] movie says over
2 million views on showers a little over
less than 500 subscribers that's not you
think that they have more is the most
positive video we've done all day hey
on this note let's end it here why did
you subscribe to this channel if people
want to do Instagram Twitter YouTube
Rene REO you can also catch on afterbuzz
TV
boom Shakalaka react series with Amber
plaster on amber plastic channel yeah
and she's going to be flying around the
country and other parts of the world
throughout the year
so keep a lookout for her on your local
Virgin America Airlines take care only
here only Airlines you do